a morning routine is fundamentally
important right now the the victory hour
that I talked about in the 5 a.m. clip
this will help you so much right now 5
to 6 a.m. the 20-20-20 formula that I
explained morning exercise morning
meditation morning journaling hydration
which means drinking lots of water you
know and have a strong morning routine
you need a really high earn clad pre
sleep ritual now is the time you want
even more sleep you want to build up and
fortify your immune system get more
sleep have lots of water get lots of
vitamin D which includes sunshine get
lots of vitamin C meditation powerful
I'd also say this is a great time for
you to rather than retract to ask
yourself how can you build your skills
read more books watch more podcasts
learn more bring more value to your
business bring more value to your
teammates bring more value to your
marketplace where so many people are
shrinking and bring more value to the
world so if you look at the great
leaders of humanity these are people
their leadership was forged when the
world was falling apart
and I would ask you and encourage you to
ask yourself how can you shift from
victimhood right now to leadership right
now I am surrounded with sanitizer and
I'm sure you guys are as well was up
Stockholm and Calgary Canada state of an
emergency issued yesterday yeah I
totally hear you same here and for me
I'm actually not someone that panics
about this sort of thing because I'm
kind of the sort of person that loves to
say like I can control everything and at
the same time I can't control with
anything and I find such bliss and
beauty in that and what I mean by that
is right now I can't control what's
going on with a corona virus and neither
can any of you guys but we can control
how we handle
and how we feel about it and then how we
pass that on to other people because if
you're freaking out
then other people around you're gonna be
freaking out so I'm always like how can
this be the best thing that's ever
happened to us
and I mean that from a Tony Robbins said
that someone's saying they just shut
down the state of PA but I work in a
hospital so a oh god take care of
yourself if you're in a hospital
and you see a Tony Robbins says how can
you take the worst thing and make it the
best thing possible and so I think
things like this really is just about
framing and how we all see things so
right now there's nothing I can do about
the actual virus itself so I'm gonna
push that out I can't control it but I
can't control how I feel and then how I
respond and come on so I'm just like how
can this be amazing okay one I get to do
an IG live with you guys unlike just the
like the random what today Monday at
2:30 in the afternoon so I never would
otherwise be able to do that with you
guys if I wasn't from home so that's one
massive positive thing second thing is I
don't get to see my husband as much we
keep running in and out but I get to see
him so I want to ask you guys right now
how can this actually be the best thing
that's ever happened to you let's stay
positive and yeah so that's how I'm
seeing this situation where are you all
doing to make use of this time and I'm
sure you've seen it you know Sir Isaac
Newton during a quarantine that's when
he developed calculus Shakespeare wrote
King Lear so there's a lot we can do
with this time especially if if this new
home working situation is is new to you
it's gonna take a little bit of
adjusting in 2008 after the economic
downturn in the housing crisis was a it
was an absolute boom for my career in
photography which you wouldn't have
thought of it and it wasn't obvious
again this is really when I triple down
on building the community that
ultimately turned into the best camera
app and creativeLIVE I put out a lot of
content because the number of jobs went
down
so you're not quite sure what format
it's gonna take and what got you to
where you are now is probably not what's
going to push you through into the next
chapter as we enter these uncertain
times but I just want you to know that
it's possible and where there's a will
there's a way continue to do what you
can
doing what you can to turn manage the
downside somebody said Italy are people
working and the answer is no for what I
understand they're in complete lockdown
and I'm an someone saying within three
years from now coronavirus will have
been only a temporary blip I think three
years from now what you're gonna see is
every year there'll be people who have
some version of the corona virus now
it's here to stay
just like SARS is here to stay just like
there was the Asian flu in 1957 people
don't remember this I don't remember it
but read about the Asian flu that
happened in 1957 killed 34,000 people in
the US and still exists to this day the
economy went into a recession but then
when it then when the recession was over
people they stopped buying things for a
little while but then they buy more
things when they come out of the
recession there's so much pent-up demand
that the economy actually surges so
that's probably what will happen here
nobody's buying now but in a quarter or
two people will buy but again take a
look at your anxiety or your fears and
and ask yourself what is the fear about
are you afraid you're gonna run out of
money what is the worst-case sir are you
afraid you're gonna get sick because
then you could look at the statistics
for you and then you could stay away
from people where are you afraid a
family members will get sick are you
afraid for your career or for your job
or you're afraid of going broke just
what's the worst-case scenario and
really figure out what you could do
about it but also realize the worst case
scenario almost never happens
every time in my life that I have ever
panicked and I thought oh my god this is
gonna happen this is Dehlia but I'm
gonna lose all my money I'm gonna I'm
gonna lose all my money and then they're
gonna throw me in jail for whatever
reason that's never happened the worst
case scenario has never happened so
understand what it is you're actually
afraid of don't don't be angry don't be
angry at this virus don't be angry at
the Chinese or about politics look
inside you
and ask what are you really afraid of
again are you afraid to get sick there
are things to do are you afraid you're
gonna lose all your money there are
things to do but analyze it and and be
honest about what you're really afraid
of fear is biological when things are
uncertain when things are uncertain it's
important to realize that fear happens
for biological reasons our ancestors if
they passed by a tree that rustled in
the wind they would run they wouldn't
step around they wouldn't wait and see
oh my gosh what's happened for causing
this tree to rustle they would run
automatically because they would be
afraid automatically the the ancestors
who stopped and said well why did this
tree leaves rustle they got eaten by
lions that's why they're not our
ancestors so our fear and our anxiety is
a natural reaction to all this
uncertainty is scary uncertainty with
the coronaviruses happening
the likelihood is you're no one you like
new it is you're not going to die from
it very few people as a percentage are
going to die from this like like most
other like every other disease out there
and the likelihood is also you're going
to be exposed no matter what you do
you're gonna be exposed to the disease
and you'll either have not get it or
you'll have no symptoms or you'll have a
few symptoms and then you'll recover I
mean in some populations people over 70
are the most at risk so those people
should stay home whatever but anyway
label your fear what are you afraid of
look at the worst-case scenario
analyze it you have to keep there's
evidence that keeping taking good care
of yourself is really important so you
have to you have to sleep well sleep
eight hours a day if you don't want to
get this disease don't have don't use I
have to not do my usual junk food binges
or whatever if I don't want to get this
stay in some shape if you want to run do
cardio because that not only does that
keep you healthy but it's a natural
antidepressant so that will help relieve
anxiety and in general this this is
gonna sound not as intuitive but do
something creative today because that's
a way of putting yourself in flow and it
absorbs you in in the thing you're
creating you know write down ten ideas
draw
right a story just even write a diary a
tree how you're feeling right now or do
something creative cuz that folk that
also is a lot of evidence it relieves
anxiety when you're in this kind of flow
state a lot of investments are ready and
I have someone managing my money and he
said unless you need the money now it's
best just to hold on to those
investments and then wait wait this out
do you think she should buy or sell I
think this person gave you really great
advice that's really good advice
I think you should just hold on because
you know selling in a panic is probably
the silliest thing you could ever do and
I'm not saying that because I think I'm
not gonna tell you what I think them all
goes tonight by the way I think the
market goes lower from here I think it
goes down to the 10 to 20 percent from
here okay I do I don't know that for a
fact but I do but still you know to be
selling because of a panic you have to
be a long-term play here should be and
hopefully your money manager sounds like
he's got his head screwed on straight or
she's has a head screwed on straight and
you know you're not gonna buy something
to sell something that any given day
because what's happening with
coronavirus right you wanna take a
longer term horizon on your investments
than that if you want to play that
timing game of getting in and getting
out I mean it's very very difficult all
right a thing that I did with my team
that I highly recommend those of you who
you know have families and those of you
who have teams is number one let them
know that their safety is your
number-one priority
their mental safety emotional safety
physical safety financial safety is your
number one concern
that's one number two reiterate that in
times like this in times of chaos fear
uncertainty volatility and everything in
between the people who stick together
win together we need each other as much
as people think well I don't need you
and you don't need me oh yes I do
oh yes you do and when things are going
great it's easy to go don't need you you
don't need me but you know what the Hugh
species is a species that bonds it's a
species that wants connection I mean
look why you want here right now you
want to connect here listen share and so
we do need each other and I'm starting
to look like Bernie Sanders now we do
need each other and when we do this I
like Bernie but you know so I want to
assure them that their safety as the CEO
of the company is my concern and that
they can come to me with any challenge
issue that they that they have my wife's
brothers are young they're 23 years old
they're like aw everybody's over
exaggerating it's no big deal the virus
isn't that bad here's the thing it
doesn't matter if the virus is like a
flu it's a pandemic this is real
businesses are shutting down the stock
market crashed and and it's gonna
fluctuate up and down we might be at the
beginning of a recession we don't it
could go to a depression or maybe it's
just a blip but here's the thing it is
here it is real and the difference of us
getting through this as a individual and
as a society depends on I believe the
yeah someone just wrote opportunity I
agree but it depends on what's going on
between here so that's what I want to
talk about today what if we took a
different perspective what if we decided
today that we were going to become role
models and leaders and be an example of
how to get through this now I want to
back up so the only way I can help with
what's currently going on is to talk
about the past so I am 51 I've been
self-employed since I was 17 years old
cutting firewood I've been blessed to
start lots of companies but that's how I
started cutting firewood fixing wrecked
cars right so I was a part of the crash
in late 80s I was a part of the crash in
2007 the shift in the crash in the
economy I was also a part of 9/11 and
this to me and I think this is the best
way I can send in love I said buddy I'm
going to try not to look bad
said in love there I'm sending love to
that was a great message but let me just
share what I believe from history 9/11
was the most similar to this okay
it was one day the world changed right
in especially here in America no matter
where you are from around the world in
America in one day
we lost sense of security Americas felt
like you know we've never really been
attacked by outside forces just Pearl
Harbor once right America hasn't been in
wars we've been protected we've been
shielded all of a sudden we are attacked
on our home land thousands of people
died overnight the world changed the
economy shifted the world shifted and
everybody was afraid to go to again I
remember not wanting to go to a
basketball game not wanting to go to the
mall like if you're super young you
barely remember if you obviously you're
over 35 you remember but it was scary
like things change and to the far right
people like the world will never be the
same especially America is ruined to the
far left it was like no big deal I don't
mean left and right like liberal
conservatives shifted right but here's
the thing during that chaos what
happened is what will happen here people
stepped up role models came into play
leaders came into play and inspired
people to come out of those shelves
inspired people to get back into the
world inspired people to action inspired
their kids their family their friends
and slowly as especially here in the
cut-in in the united states slowly we
gained our confidence and then it
compounded and and now it's like oh yeah
the 9/11 thing it was tragic for so many
people but it was a part of our history
and that's what I want to encourage you
to when you look throughout time no
matter if you're 20 30 40 50 or 60 or
older remember this just like seasons
right yep it goes from spring and to
summer and summer into fall and fall
into winter our world go is secularism
cycles we've had summer for a long time
it's been beautiful it's been the best
economy in the world for the last ten
years it's been like oh this is perfect
but winter came really
fast now I don't know how long winters
gonna last I'm not an economist I'm I
could tell you how long this will be
down but here's what I know winter is
here at this moment it could be the
start of a recession or it could be a
blip but the difference in your family
the difference for you is going to be
your perception of this situation see it
might hit you okay I'm gonna back up so
many people I've had a couple people say
yeah that's not gonna affect my industry
this is gonna affect everyone let me
just tell you it's gonna affect everyone
some people in a massively positive way
and some people in a negative way if you
are in the information business if
you're on the in the online world if
you're part of the digital economy if
you're selling knowledge if you're part
of the knowledge industry in my opinion
and in my experience when when things
like this happen people want to learn
more specialized knowledge from home
online if you're in that industry
step into it you have the opportunity to
excel and help people right but other
industries are going to be hurt so just
know there's gonna be repercussions but
you know who comes out on top not the
person who invents something not the
person who takes advantage of people
during times like this you know what
takes wins is those that can find a
mindset to be a role model and a leader
during these times if you want more
advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there the whole
issue of using your hands touching your
face of people I'll concentrate on